hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast understanding cancer through
whole genome screening is presented by
Andrew Ravenel a PhD senior Rd scientist
for genome and epigenome editing at Mill
par Sigma I am Judy al-raqqa Bluebirds
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by milla par Sigma
for more information about our sponsor
visit w-w-w our Sigma comm before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. robin le i will
now turn the presentation over to him
all right thank you for joining this
webinar my name is Andy Ravenel E and
I'll be discussing functional genomic
screening approaches to discovering
genes and pathways that are relevant to
cancer and to other cellular phenotypes
so the life science business of Merck
KGaA
in darmstadt germany operates as milla
poor Sigma in the US and Canada and I'm
a senior R&D scientist with Miller for
Sigma in the genome engineering division
so cancer is of course the uncontrolled
and unregulated growth of cells which
metastasized throughout the body there
are a number of capabilities acquired
during the multi step development of
human tumors that promotes cancerous
behavior cancer can be considered a
genome disease
level and the sequencing and mapping of
the human genome has really paved the
way for cancer genomics and is being
used to define molecular targets for
tumor specific properties remarkable
progress has been made regarding
mechanism based targeted therapies and
has really been informed by these
hallmark characteristics a handful of
examples of which are presented here new
therapeutics are often designed against
specific molecular targets that enable
one or more of these capabilities in
cells so in principle these targeted
approaches have relatively fewer off
target effects and thus nonspecific
toxicity however in reality positive
clinical outcomes really are often
transitory and followed by relapses and
tumor resurgence so this may be due to
some redundancy in signaling pathways or
because tumors may shift their
dependence between hallmark abilities as
they evolve and so a powerful strategy
is then to take a functional genomics
approach to develop a comprehensive
understanding of the genes and pathways
that direct the adoption of tumorigenic
cellular behaviors such that more
effective long-term approaches can be
developed and utilized so what is
functional genomics then functional
genomics is a field of study that
examines the relationships between genes
and complex cellular processes on a
genome-wide scale from a foundation of
genome sequencing and high-throughput
analysis it can involve things like
mutagenesis targeted gene knockouts and
noggins activation and repression of
transcription transgenic over expression
of genes or disruption of protein
translation the most comprehensive use
of these approaches are in genome scale
screens that allow for discovery of
relevant gene function so the ease at
which one can use functional genomic
tools to target many genes at once has
really opened up the possibilities and
the accessibility for whole genome
screening we now offer or often rely on
short non
rnase that can be transfected or in the
case of CRISPR expressed along with cast
nine or transduced in viral formats for
delivery genetic screens are unbiased
and they allow for discovery of drug and
disease relevant pathways and phenotypes
that were not previously considered loss
of function and gain of function screens
are complementary to each other and
screens are very high throughput and
they can yield whole genome resolution
screens are efficient and accessible
ways to dissect and understand gene
function targeting tools are designed
strategically for optimal targeting to
increase confidence in your phenotypic
see and they really require much less
time and cost than protein based screens
like zinc finger nucleases and talons
for example so sigma-aldrich and now
milik or Sigma has a long history of
expertise in functional genomics
screening tools so I mean over a decade
ago with our whole genome SHR Ares our
portfolio has grown often through
collaborations with leaders like the
Broad Institute and the Wellcome Trust
Sanger Center and we were the very first
to offer Cris for reagents and received
multiple awards over the years for our
innovations and offerings in CRISPR
epigenetics and CRISPR screening tools
there are two primary types of screens
for which we offer support and that are
useful for functional genomic analysis
pooled screens which combine thousands
of clones into a single tube and arrayed
screens which consists of thousands of
unique wells of individual clones pool
screens allow for rapid identification
of relevant target genes while arrayed
screens are perfect for high content
imaging and cellular phenotyping on a
fine scale pooled screens are generally
the most widely used and are pretty
straightforward and upfront but they
require much more about time and expense
investments on the back end during
theta-d convolution
and follow us there's a raid screens
require a much more substantial upfront
investment of labor but can yield a much
broader diversity of data points and and
much less back-end effort because all of
the data's really already been collected
so what do some of these libraries look
like the first category contains
knockout gene editing tools and we offer
both a raid and pooled library
approaches the Sanger array
CRISPR library made in conjunction with
the Wellcome Trust Sanger Center
contains CRISPR guide RNAs for over
17,000 genes with two individually
arrayed guides for each gene the guide
plasmid contains a blue fluorescent
protein cassette which is useful for
visualizing transduction or transfection
efficiency of the library and in
addition to the whole genome array of
library we've also developed smaller
panels derived using up-to-date expert
curated CRISPR data exists instead of
relying on a single individual or a
single source for gene family lists
we've come by combined and compiled and
cross-referenced numerous resources that
including the peg database gene ontology
sets the druggable genome database from
experts like Wash U and our own manual
curation of PubMed IDs so this is an
ongoing exercise that allows us to
create non redundant research focused
gene panels a variety of cellular
functions and categories which includes
of five cancer related gene panels
importantly for this these small panels
can be customized to include or exclude
any number of genes or you can design
fully bespoke panels of your own gene
sets and for those budget mind these
focused panels allow for targeted array
and screening at a lower cost so the
real power of a raid screening is in the
ability to incorporate high content
imaging and analysis across a range of
metrics
and a handful of examples are listed
here for this cells are plated in 96
well plates and they're treated with the
clone library followed by another
selection or phenotyping wells are then
analyzed individually and assayed for
features like cell death and
proliferation cell morphology or
reporter fluorescence because each well
is assessed individually and can include
multicolor imaging mixed populations of
cells can be analyzed within a single
well this becomes incredibly useful when
considering the heterogeneity within the
tumor micro-environment tumor cells are
often mixed with cells of normal
function to promote tumor growth and
tumor maintenance over time and then
individual gene function can then be
assessed to dissect particular cell cell
interactions within this arrayed screen
high content imaging also allows for
more fine scale image analysis using for
example subcellular protein localization
so in this example scat 1 and stat 3
proteins have been fused to gfp and RFP
respectively revealing cytoplasmic
localization of these proteins on the
top
under normal conditions but then upon
stimulation with type 2 interferon for
example stat proteins then translocate
to the nucleus and you can see nuclear
localization of this staining or this
GFP and RP fluorescence software
detection of cytoplasmic versus nuclear
staining then elevates the utility of
this system to allow for high content
image analysis of protein localization
in response to disrupted gene function
for example using the Sanger arrayed
library knockout of stat 3 here using
the Sanger arraign CRISPR guides results
in a significant decrease in our fp+
cells as you can see in the middle and
this figure also shows the usefulness of
having the BFP incorporated into the
guide plasmid to ensure that you
achieved effective delivery and that
these guides are capable of an
TRUCKING gene function in cells that
have taken up this cassette so in
addition to the arrayed libraries we
offer both the gecko
CRISPR pool that was developed by the
Broad Institute as well as our own Sigma
CRISPR pool and these libraries have
great utility in nakao screening in cell
culture and an enviable models as
evidenced by this really cool paper from
Phil sharps lab identifying critical
genes driving tumor Genesis and various
tumor subtypes upon injection of cells
that were treated with the Gecko whole
genome CRISPR library into
immunocompromised mice
so although knockout technologies have
been established and adopted across
multiple platforms there's really been a
lot of new excitement lately in the
development of tools that regulate gene
function independent of changing the DNA
CRISPR activation and CRISPR inhibition
for example offer all of the sequence
specific targeting of the CRISPR complex
to deliver a factor domains that
regulate transcription of genes we
recently launched a set of new CRISPR
activator tools so why had CRISPR
activators and CRISPR screening then to
your toolbox CRISPR a is complementary
to existing loss-of-function
technologies as each of these enriches
four different sets of genes responsible
for the same phenotype
unlike loss-of-function technologies
CRISPR a is fairly unique for
gain-of-function screening and because
it's nucleus independent and the design
rules are fairly strict the risk of off
targeting effects are substantially
lower with CRISPR a with CRISPR
activators there's really little to no
risk of genome instability from
double-stranded breaks again because
there's no cutting and when performing
knockout screening using a cancer cell
line sometimes you have to worry about
the ability to completely knock out high
copy number genes and this really isn't
a concern for activation screens and by
activating transcription that the
endogenous locus instead of transgenic
over expression of a gene for example of
a defined isoform CRISPR a allows cell
to dictate isoform
pression and splice variation so George
church's lab published a nice comparison
paper of the different CRISPR activator
technologies and showed CRISPR Sam to be
the strongest transcriptional activator
system
that's why we chose to optimize and
produce the CRISPR Sam lentiviral whole
genome libraries so the CRISPR
synergistic activation mediator or Sam
was described by Feng John's group at
the Broad Institute and is a three part
CRISPR based transcriptional activator
complex and its core is the D caste nine
VP 64 protein that forms the basic
synthetic transcription factor and it
complexes with a guide RNA to form the
RMP targeting complex but the stem and
tetra loops of the guide scaffold in
this context have been modified to
contain RNA after MERS that bind and
recruit additional transcriptional
co-activators to the complex to help
maximize transcriptional output we found
that the original vectors could benefit
from some functional Lenti tighter
optimization so our new modified Venter
backbone produces substantially higher
levels of functional virus so that our
new functional titer for Sam means the
efficiency that's required for whole
genome screening with a pooled library
of guides to achieve the desired levels
of coverage so the CRISPR Sam library
follows a fairly universal guide design
rule improving guy design efficiency the
library was validated using a whole
genome screen for B RAF inhibitor
resistance in a 375 cells BRF is the
most potent activator of the map kinase
pathway and this pathway is mutated in
an estimate estimated 30 percent of all
cancers with mutations in BRF
specifically found in approximately 7%
of all cancers and nearly all of the
observed mutations in B RAF are the same
as the one Harvard by these a 375 be
reviewing melanoma cells resulting in
constitutive activation of the pathway
these cells are integrated with then
integrated with Sam helper components
and then transduced with the guide
library
the B RAF inhibitor plx 4720 was used to
enrich for resistant cells that escaped
selection genomic DNA is then harvested
and guide representation was established
by next-generation sequencing analysis
so during our initial validation a lot
of the library we showed high guide
representation across the library for a
number of different cell lines and
screening approaches and as you can see
in the graph above for the B RAF
inhibitor screen we showed strong
enrichment of a cohort of guides that
had circled in blue following B RAF
inhibitor selection so our screen
produced EGFR as our top hit on the
right by magic analysis matching the top
hit from earlier studies from Ken Jong's
lab and others that EGFR is critical for
mediating this this pathway in this
resistance we also pulled out a V RAF or
mutant bee rat in this case validating
another study showing that over
expression of this gene can overcome
drug inhibition so top hits from the
cone airman Sam screen from Feng Zhang's
group were then validated using
individual guides for improved survival
under selection and showed increased
mRNA and protein resulting from
transcriptional activation analyzed by Q
PCR and Western blots in this schematic
of the pathways implicated in
proliferation and survival of these
cancers we can see that the established
models of reactivation of the Rask
pathway and the parallel pathway of pi3
kinase Akt signaling the top pins from
the screen are highlighted in blue
lettering where those previously
validated using an ortho ver expression
library approach have been underlined in
green so importantly a number of novel
genes are now implicated in B RAF
inhibitor resistance from this including
a family of itg receptors not previously
described so this green really shows the
importance of using complementary
approaches to identifying relevant genes
and pathways to your phenotype of
interest because they can reveal
distinct
sets of genes and interactions that
might otherwise remain undiscovered and
that may open up new avenues than for
therapeutic exploration so finally I'd
like to discuss a tool separate of
CRISPR using an established mechanism of
gene repression and translation
inhibition of RNA I so we offer a number
of shRNA screening platforms both pooled
and arrayed for whole genome focused and
custom libraries for this I'd like to
highlight an exciting paper from earlier
this year that provides a comprehensive
look at functional genomic discovery
from a forward genetic screen to
clinical relevance in this study from
the Gomez lab combined an experimental
mouse model for tumor metastasis with a
genome wide screen to ask what genes
regulate dormancy in these disseminated
tumor cells so they injected a dormant
bone metastatic or DBM these are luminal
er breast cancer derived cells into
immunocompromised mice the goal of the
screen was to probe the genetic basis
for several characteristics of these
cells first these cells injected these
injected cells disseminate and
subsequently undergo homing to the bone
tissue they next undergo a period of
dormancy or latency whereby no resulting
lesions or secondary metastases form for
many months in these mice similar to how
they function in humans for many many
years or decades finally upon some
uncharacterized stimulus they exit the
latent phase and lead to symptomatic
lesions and metastasis so for the screen
they applied the whole genome mission
shrna library to dbm cells intensive
pools and sequenced cells for
representation the ten sub poles were
subsequently injected into into the
ventricles of ten mice each and after
four months the resultant lesions were
harvested and sequenced to reveal shRNA
enrichment so genes that were known to
regulate proliferation and they pop
ptosis were excluded from this analysis
and they were left with a list of about
320 genes from there only two of the
candidates were found in at least two
lesions and with at least two
independent shrnas and the authors chose
to follow up on one of these for
exploration and that's the gene that
encodes in SK 1 so the MS k1 shrnas were
then validated by Western blot for
protein levels and by homing assay to
the bone and further validated using
CRISPR knockout on the right showing a
similar response these cells were then
transplanted into mice and assessed for
symptomatic metastasis ms k1 knockdown
correlates with a decreased bone
metastasis free survival in addition to
a deeper dive into the molecular
mechanism of MS k1 activity which I'm
not covering here and the author's
really went comprehensive on this they
examined bone biopsies from patients
with er-positive breast cancer and found
that bone metastases free survival
positively correlated with high levels
of MS k1 so that they then could
potentially stratify patients for
potential prognosis and included that MS
k1 regulates expression of
differentiation genes in luminal breast
tissue and then in the absence of MS k1
differentiation programs are compromised
and can lead to metastatic progression
of these cells so this paper and studies
like it really exemplify how the utility
of unbiased forward genetic screens and
functional genomic analysis can reveal
novel gene pathways and functions that
have direct relevance to clinical
outcomes for patients with cancer and
they can provide an excellent starting
point for the development of novel drugs
and therapeutic approaches to improve
development pipelines
so although whole genome screening is
pretty straightforward and shouldn't be
scary if you use our kits and reagents
there are a number of considerations to
explore before you start any screen
screens take reagents and they take man
and they really take time and you need
to know the ins and outs of your cell
line or your approach as it pertains to
proliferation rates karyotype drug
resistance and transduction efficiency
for example you need to understand the
effect of your drug on your cells for
example how long do you need to screen
with your drug to get a good enrichment
or phenotype and you need to have clear
expectations for your phenotypic
outcomes so that you're going at this
and a really strategic and targeted
manner next-generation sequencing
requires expertise in the use of
specialized equipment or access to it
and in bioinformatics support and you
need to try to anticipate how you'll go
about validating your top hits and
following up on your screen these are
all pretty standard but there are things
that you're really going to want to
include in your planning before you
start a screen so we've covered a lot of
ground so I'll just finish with a
summary of the options that you have
when looking for functional genomics
screening tools we have an extensive
portfolio of gene editing and expression
reagents that includes lentivirus
DNA and RNA formats along with synthetic
ala goes and RNAs and proteins for
whatever suits your individual needs
there are a number of library options
from pools to arrays both off-the-shelf
and custom panels of a variety of
sciences and we offer formats for
knockdown and knockout and activation
and over expression screening which can
even be performed in parallel or
complementarily to one another and just
as important we have the historical and
the technical expertise to support you
and your projects all along the way and
I really hope that you'll reach out to
us if you have any questions about how
we could possibly help you with your
next CRISPR or genome engineering or
functional genomics project so I hope
that you come away from this excited to
explore screening approaches to enhance
your research pipelines and I'd really
love to trying to answer any questions
that you might have in the remaining
time but if for some reason we get cut
off please feel free to email me at
Andrew Ravenel II at sial dot-com or
at NOLA for Sigmund calm and thank you
for listening thank you dr. Ravin le for
that informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
take your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email let's get
started the first question is would you
expect a CRISPR knockout or Sam
activator screen to be able to discover
the MS k1 target so would we be able to
find creme SK one with either a knockout
or an activation stream that ultimately
depends on the context if you're doing
the same screen
I wouldn't necessarily if you're doing
the exact same screening approach using
the same drug I wouldn't necessarily
expect to find the same genes in both a
knockout screen or an and an activator
screen but you could using these two
screens you could approach the same
signaling pathway or the same protein
interactions or gene interactions from
two different angles and identify
different pathway members along the way
but using because the targets and the
guides that target each of these genes
like ms k1 are present in both a
knockout or an shRNA or a CRISPR
activator library you would expect to
find that gene in screening depending on
the context of your screen thank you
next one is you show thousand-fold
activation with your Sam library what is
the maximum level of activation the
system can achieve so that's a great
question and it's another kind of
hedging answer the same activators one
of my favorite one of my favorite
projects to work on and so the most
important thing and really what the
power of the CRISPR Sam activator system
is is that because you're regulating
gene function from the
Dodge's Lucas it absolutely context in
which you are trying to achieve
activation or inhibition is very much
dependent upon the cells and the current
physiology of whatever cells are selling
you're using so we are the the CRISPR
Sam system activates at the endogenous
locus if that locus is already highly
active and expressed in your cell line
you can't recruit more transcriptional
machinery to that locus so if the gene
is already expressed at very high levels
you're not going to see much if any
activation you will see much much higher
activation the lower the gene is
expressed and you you can avoid unlike
transgenic over expression you can avoid
toxic over expression of genes with this
system because again we're using the
cell's endogenous transcriptional
machinery at the cell's locus in the
genome so it depends on the context is
one approach more powerful than another
for instance is a raid or pulled
screening more effective in finding
candidate genes I think I'll have the
same answer for pretty much every single
question it's context dependent but
pooled screening it depends on what you
mean by power and a raid screening and
pooled screening should be able to if
your screen that if you're using this
these with the same context of a single
drug or a single phenotype should be
able to pull out a similar list of genes
although genes with genes that give more
subtle cellular phenotypes may fall out
in a pooled screen whereas those may be
able to be brought to the forefront in a
raid screen because you can see every
single well assessed individually so you
can see all of the genes that are
responsible for a particular phenotype
in an arranged screen whereas in a
pooled approach you'll see the top the
top hits that will come out or the most
important or the the genes that were
responsible for the strongest enrichment
and from those in either either of the
pool screening context you would choose
which hits to follow up on for further
validation and continued study so
neither one of them is more powerful
than any other one necessarily it just
depends on what approach you were more
interested in how many guides you can
follow up in and what type of screening
approaching what type of data you want
to get if you want to get detailed
phenotypic data or fluorescent data or
protein localization you need to use an
arranged screen if your system is
high-throughput looking for cell
survival or cell death a pooled approach
is definitely a fast way to get to that
information yes and last one is our
biological replicates required for
pooled screening yes that's a simple
answer biological and technical
replicates from a scientific or from an
experimental perspective are always
required to achieve statistical
significance if you want statistical
significance if this is just a pilot and
you're looking for a candidate list of
genes to follow up on as you would
pretty much with any screen then you
don't necessarily need biological
replicates but for maximizing your
confidence in what your top hits are
this is you'll always want to have
biological replicates screens are always
going to be hypothesis generators or
broad approaches to give you a list of
genes to follow up on they will never
give you the answer to your question
never give you all of the phenotypic
data that you need to address gene
function or or functional genomics
screens are always the first step toward
a more in-depth and thoughtful and
comprehensive study and so forth at
biological replicates are excellent and
necessary for getting statistical
significance
but you're definitely going to follow up
with much more comprehensive research
programs for your top hits when you get
done thank you I would like to once
again thank dr. Robin Ellie for his
presentation I would also like to thank
Milla for Sigma for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 11th
2019 you'll receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay we
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye thank you very much